[موسيقى]
الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مصدر عسكري في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره حين استخبارات منطقه
البحر الاحمر صادرت اسلحه وذخائر جنوبيه
محليه سواكن بولايه البحر الاحمر شرقيه
البلاد قادمه من دوله اجنبيه وكانت في
طريقها الى ما وصفهم او وصفهم المصدر
بالمتمردين
قال مصدر دبلوماسي سوداني مطلع للجزيره ان
ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده بالسودان
لن يعود مجددا الى السودان رغم تعبير
الامين العام للمنظمه الدوليه انطونيو
فيه واضاف المصدر ان البعث الامميه في
السودان ستواصل عملها بشكل اعتيادي الى
حين اختيار بديل بتشاور مع الخرطوم
وكان الرئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان قد طلب من الامين العام للامم
المتحده بترشيح بديل لممثله الخاص في
السودان
اقل المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ستيفان دو جاريث للجزيره ان
الامين العام فخور بعمل مبعوثه الخاص الى
السودان ويؤكد على ثقته الكامله به
اعلنت سلطات ودنيتك المواليه لروسيا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت محيط مصنع
ازوستال في مدينه ماريوبول بصاروخين بعيدي
المدى ولم يسفر القصف وفق السلطات عن
اضراره
قال حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان طائره مسيره
قذفتين متفجرتين على احدى المناطق ونشر
تنظيم يطلق على نفسه اسم فيلق حريه روسيا
مقطعا يظهر جانبا مما قالينها عمليات في
بيل جراد
قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان الجيش
الاوكراني يحتاج الى نحو 48 طائره مقاتله
من طراز اف 16 لتحرير الاراضي التي تحتلها
روسيا وفق بيان الوزاره
اندلعت مواجهات بين شرطه كوسوفو ومواطنين
من اصول صربيه احرقت خلالها سيارات للشرطه
في البلديه الشماليه على الحدود مع صربيا
وقالت الشرطه انها تتخذ اجراءات وتدابير
لمنع جميع الانشطه الاجراميه وحمل الكبير
الموظفين في رئاسه كوسوفو صربيا مسؤوليه
التصعيد في المناطق الشماليه من كوسوفو
واعلن الرئيس الصربي الكسندر وضع الجيش في
حاله تاهب قتالي قصوى وامر وحداته
بالاقتراب من الحدود مع كوسوفو اقل وزير
الدفاع الصربي انه اصدر اوامر بتحرك قواته
بشكل عاجل الى حدود كوسوفو
في بيان مشترك عبرت كل من الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا وايطاليا والمانيا
وبريطانيا عن ادانتها قرار حكومه كوسوفو
بالدخول بالقوه الى المباني البلديه في
شمال كوسوفو رغم الدعوه الى ضبط النفس وقد
دعت الدول الخمس سلطات كوسوفو الى التراجع
على الفور ووقف التصعيد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]